display i mean 999 feingold with approve
oh let me okay there's a few things I
have to do first of all smooth my thing
like that okay and let's play E for and
I think I'll I'll get rid of the music
even if it's like very peaceful sounding
maybe later I'll do a straw poll to see
whether people want this or not but okay
putting it back to standard
let's play some normal opening I'll play
I'll play a Spanish because why not
I'll take tour the noggin with approve
of this but I don't think toilet Nagin
is here hopefully other people approve
Bishop d6 Bishop d6 I think d4 should be
played at some points and maybe right
now hello to people
mmm singer lonely pawn the real luck
duck
Henry SD prawn sacrifice Bishop g4 okay
being slightly aggressive so if I take
black would have to take the knight
first I take looks pretty reasonable for
whites the bishops kind of exposed on e5
maybe some move like Queen b3 and I for
or 92 to c4 so yeah let's take the fish
up takes I win a piece so take here now
it's a question do I play Queen b3 92 to
c4 looks very straightforward
because this should come with tempo and
I have a nice structure already that's
the one benefit of playing the exchange
ROI just slightly better structure
usually white is okay with trading
nicéphore I allow the trade maybe Queen
b3
defending and attacking and preparing
this or this whoa castling queenside
that wasn't not expected I kind of like
this move I also like this move if I
play Knight of three I'm threatening
Bishop g5
I'm also maybe trying to - just watching
on YouTube Samsonite yeah I posted a
YouTube video like a hour ago of my my
arena King's performance from like a
month ago I think the video already has
like 500 views Knight f3
you know I have three black house to
respond I can win the bishop let's do
this I'm not sure whether this will be
like positional or tactical or maybe
both why does it say you're not online
my not online pretty sure I'm online I'm
making moves and my opponent is making
moves in response oh is a Lee chess
thing not detecting my stream yeah I'm
not sure let's do this
maybe it'll it takes a moment or
something okay wait nine h6i Bishop g5
tactics Bishop g5 pretty sure this is
winning material
yeah 96 I think was just a blunder
probably had to play h6 remove the Queen
of the bishop wait you don't see me
online on Twitch or on Oh Bishop takes
h2 or on leech s unli chess
oh it's detecting my stream maybe if i
refresh it's not showing here because I
started the stream and then started the
game like right away but if i refresh it
should it should now say that I'm
streaming
sometimes it takes a moment flummox 1 2
3 thanks for subbing for 2 months ok so
I'm up at peace Oh am i winning more
material a 5 here here take stakes and I
won the rook in the end so yeah I'll
just be up a full recommend hey you
finally call the twitch stream
congratulations twitch streams are not
as easy to catch as YouTube videos
alright let's take a look
and let's just simplify York t1 go for
the rook trade what you like to get a
tie - OH - I refuse to sub again next
month if I don't see g5 hash ball then
hee hee hee hee at the end that's great
ok so many things to address what do I
start with g5 hash g5 hash yeah it's
hard to like orchestrate like a very
specific type of meat
I could try I'll try my best
I have to work for the the resub
confronting this and this defends let's
do this so my favorite dish at Thai - OH
- is sometimes always changing but I do
really like the the chicken pod Cu or
the pineapple fried rice it used to be
the pod thai but I haven't had pot eye
in a while
that's - this tadka now is also good I
haven't had something that isn't laughs
again
it's worth the bits just to have the a I
say hehehe
okay I'm on the back ring mates complete
u6 could maybe play this move hitting
the rook but also hitting the pawn mmm
it's Louie six
I'm fantasizing about this this and then
meet interesting I think I'll just give
away that pawn yeah and now this Queen
takes CA there's a nice maiden - okay
that's nice exchange Roy yeah black just
fell victim to some simple tactic like
neither of three was kind of an innocent
developing move but had a threat to it
which was missed
I mean after age six it still fights
maybe I would end up taking and playing
positionally I see Marvin asking if I'm
taking challenges I guess I am I have
eleven pending challenges if you're a
sub you can use a the Lee chess command
to connect your Lee chess account to
your twitch name and then it should show
a purple here just like what what messy
Marvin did in the chat showing messy
Marvin offline
okay let's accept a game with messy
Marvin and maybe he'll return which is a
ma and the tags mean it's funny huh when
you ask that question you're you're
exercising you're a ma right ma stands
for ask me anything so that's that's a
valid question to ask
okay so I'm playing a slightly unusual
London so-called berry attack ideas
filet h5 and maybe sac the exchange h5
is a very standard move for luck
normally the idea for white is to just
put a knight on e5 and be happy
control the center and we might end up
trading on e2 sometimes black will take
and then I'll take with Bishop hmm se5
is interesting in similar positions in
black play c5 there sometimes might be
five but the combination of a six and c5
because is very reasonable I'm wondering
if I can just take it be greedy can
still go for this as well I think I'll
play 95 because now black has to do
something with the bishop and I mean in
the meantime which can I take with the
Knights make some sense
I'll take with Queen my Knights has some
purpose here to pressure d5 and maybe
someday for apari for oh yeah White's a
bit ahead and developments like very
soon I might Castle and play e4 or g4 I
take on c5
good take out c5 but then queen 85
we're calculating this this this and
then this 94 could be very strong in the
end it's like a so I have to worry about
C 4 and E 4 let's castle so whenever
your rucks are connected it means you've
completed the opening so I've completed
the opening Black has not completed the
opening which means I'm more developed
and maybe I can try and open the center
because box King wherever it goes on the
board
I'll have potential to attack like on
the Queen side on the Kings side in the
center so I think e 4 is a very thematic
move here there's actually a game and
I've shown this in I shown this in an
online lecture I showed this in the st.
Louis chess club lecture once but it
wasn't recorded never made it to YouTube
as a game between Greece shook and cous
new dean off and it was from the same
opening slightly different position but
the key moment was when like play d4
just to completely bust open the
position
some of these questions I'm very
confused about
six silly sisters asking if I can show
the challenges yeah these are the people
challenging I know you can't see all of
them because I'm covering some of them
but there you are diamond-cut is at the
very end b5 so b5 I could take on d5 and
then just have every center square
occupied so if I take on d5 most likely
black will take twice and then maybe
rook e1 maybe I should play rook he1
first you can also take this way first
I'm dreaming of some line like rook H e1
d4 takes takes takes takes and the night
takes g6
and mating on e7 yeah let's start with
rook e1 very nice x-ray vision the
e-file battery okay I'm gonna try and
answer the non disturbing questions and
also address some non disturbing
comments I think his voice sounds really
nice well thank you bold with many DS
what if my opening involves a rook lift
because I'm a very manly player more
this I guess we'll never know
favorite opening is black that isn't
played much staffer gambit or the
budapest gambit i like my my aggressive
and maybe slightly unsound gambits
especially against low rated players
I'll definitely see some of those later
in an arena kings
what was your largest or fastest rating
boost to what do you attribute this
boost I think there were two standout
moments but okay I mean when I started
playing chess my first rating was 631
and then within the matter of like a
year I gained of like 500 points but
that's maybe not as impressive as some
like later boosts
where I gained perhaps a few hundred
points at like a high rating level
castling is very respectable okay but
let's not try and show too much respect
I want to play g4 I feel like this game
is ripe for a g5 meet someday someway I
mean f3 is logical
maybe g4 immediately I'm liking g4
immediately because the night this
nights a bit overworked it's doing so
many jobs and I mean ideally also
defending h5 so I mean it's a useful
square for the night but at some points
the night will have to either commit to
going to defy or taking on each v and
then something will fall I'm realizing
maybe I'm not gonna achieve g5 mates I'm
potentially sacking my gf on or playing
g5 too soon my threat is probably to
play g5 or maybe to take I probably just
have taken open the G file
Xander Shepherd with a sub that's a new
name Eric might be the only ten minute
blitz dreamer is that what I am now a 10
minute blitz streamer this is actually
concerted rapid chess
I think anything 10 minutes are longer
maybe other sites consider it let's h g4
so I could take this way
No yeah now the night will be removed
one way or the other if my takes G for
Queen Jake c4 and then this is hits and
also h5 is coming if Knight takes e4 and
then I'll probably trade twice hit the
rook or ok7 and still h5 ideas I have a
preference between Raiden and casual
games for challenges not really I mean
if you want rated usually if it's rated
I take it a bit more seriously sometimes
I just don't know if I'm playing like
Zen mode that doesn't tell me if it's
rated or shot so I have an option here I
could take the knight first or I can
take the pawn first probably take the
knight this way I keep some initiative
and probably Queen takes at the rook an
h5 coming soon
like the whole idea of the King side
attack is to open up files so the G
files half open I would like to make it
fully open have more scope against the
king yeah that's expected
and this looks interesting
idea of like night isse Evan yeah let's
do this there's some weak squares like
I'm controlling see seven and a seven
more than than black as ideas at should
be six if I get in ninety seven King
moves over I play each five there could
very well be like potential mating ideas
on the H file some ninety seven if King
I feel I have Bishop d6
so it's probably a choice between these
two moves
if King age 7 its alignment with my
queen I can play this
if King each eights I still play this
could get a bit weird let's we'll see
what happens
chaste poems is back and DJ running
congratulating me on the arena kings
yeah that video was from like a month
ago but thank you since then I have not
been performing that well in an arena
kings so Bishop d6 I mean this looks
very very nice
now the King's stuck and black can't
take without losing everything it is
still a question how I meet maybe the
knight will move to attack the bishop
there should be multiple ways to win
this thanks for the host Ches phones
Queen b6 lets a move o Queen b6 can I
have do I really have this move Knight
c8 Knight c8 so multi-purpose defending
my Bishop threatening the Queen
unleashing my Bishop to check the King
and then also preventing the rooks from
defending each other so if Knight c8
queen takes g6 I have Queen takes ei
mate and if King g8 I mean I take the
rook and then win the Queen such a
beautiful move so checking attacking the
Queen and threatening mate in one
I was very thumbnail worthy nice game
messy Marvin I think the opening was
fine for black but something went
terribly wrong like at some point maybe
even after like C for the position
became unpleasant because e4 before I
think black already has some issues
might be better to leave the tension and
play this does it's a bit more difficult
for me to play e4 if d4 is attacked a
few times there's also a queen 85
immediately which could be interesting
so the game Lucretia we should couse
Medina I'll make a new study
Center pond and London berry attack so
oh I have to go to the previous game I'm
just gonna find my game here so we'll
copy the link address and we'll add it
as a new chapter actually wait let me
call this study
efore but efore comes not on unmoved one
but later in the game now I have I did a
quick google search of the Kree ship
game now I'll grab the URL from this
here copy and then add as a new chapter
[Music]
there we go okay so if we compare like
what happened the game thank you for I
think white should be better let's see
what soccer says if we go back here I'm
just saying castling immediately the
castling always runs into g4 if there's
anything better okay it's it's a
playable position I guess but if we look
at the the greece ship game a very
similar structure like same same sort of
opening at least two starts and maybe a
few differences but this position again
efore and the finish this game was
amazing easy for i mean it opens up a
lot more possibilities black castles if
your takes takes
a really nice move for whites rook h3
someone was talking earlier about rook
lifts and being manly it's a very manly
rock lift I guess ideas of this and this
but yeah well I just kept full
initiative and 97 beautiful move
threatening meets and then Queen f3
threatening the night so I was attacking
from all directions and Bishop c7 the
icing on the cake so yeah if anyone
wants to analyze on their own I'll share
the study link in the chat but for now
let's move on